five at four this is eight news now the
Las Vegas housing market has experienced
highs and lows right but as the year
draws to a close and the holidays
approach one Las Vegas real estate
expert saying buyers and sellers can
still find success after a year of
fierce competition and high prices
we have about four casinos going up two
more sports teams supposedly going to be
announced that's thousands of jobs
coming into Las Vegas that means
thousands of people are going to be
moving around and moving means buying
and selling homes that anticipated
growth along with home prices dropping
and competition to buy them thinning all
make what local real estate expert Kirby
Scofield considers a great time to buy
in Las Vegas now there's no denying many
homeowners are holding off since
mortgage rates have doubled since the
beginning of the year but to keep it in
perspective rates fell to record lows
during the pandemic then with inflation
surging 30-year mortgage rates last
month surpassed the seven percent Mark
but are still below their historical
average of nearly eight percent
Schofield says instead of looking at
buying a home based off the rate find
one that is Affordable to you utilize
that it's current a buyer's market to
get seller concessions to help buy down
the points and pay for your closing
costs to make you get keys into the home
that you actually deserve he adds
first-time home buyers requiring only a
three and a half percent down payment
through an FHA Home Loan are seeing a
trend that's definitely in their favor
when it comes to options more homes
available in FHA limit double right now
then we had an inventory in just January
long a January alone of every home total
in Vegas
he says it's also a good time to list
your home although it may take longer to
sell buyers are more serious about
purchasing if they're looking during the
holiday season and he adds you've got
Equity built into your home use it to
help negotiate the right price and right
terms